Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and no you aren’t
dreaming, Stephen Amell was spotted leaning
in for a Felicity Kiss in a new Arrow Season
3 Promo.
I’ll explain what’s going on.
But in response to the craziness I’m going
to do my top 5 superhero couples.
Plus, some big news.
Rila Fukushima is replacing Devin Aoki as
Katana.
I’ll explain what happened there too.
Important stuff first.
If you were on twitter last night you may
have seen the hashtag Olicity Kiss flying
around.
It was a little mysterious because the CW
hadn’t posted any official videos to social.
But yet, there was a super short video of
Oliver almost kissing Felicity.
When you zoom in what’s going on is he’s
leaning in and whispering something too her.
If you remember the finale moment where “Slade
Took The Wrong Woman”?
It’s kind of like that, where oliver is
rather ambiguously showing affection and communicating
something secret.
There’s no context for the scene so don’t
take it at face value.
The show does a great job of building the
Olicity sexual tension without trampling on
the future.
In the spirit of that, here’s my top 5 Comic
Book Couples, these are from any verse, not
just Marvel and DC.
Number 5 - Black Panther and Storm, Marvel’s
biggest Royal Couple
Bringing them together was a huge deal for
the fandom after the Civil War arc, but behind
the scenes it was also the big thing connecting
the X-Men franchise to the Avengers.
Marvel’s two biggest teams.
They were both born as royalty so it was also
like a comic book version of the royal wedding.
Marvel has always had a lot of fun with epic
weddings.
I think the wedding of Jean Grey in 1994 was
the next biggest thing in comics after the
Death of Superman arc and the Batman Knightfall
saga.
Cyclops and Jean Grey were never my favorite
couple though.
Recently things have not gone so hot, the
X-Men vs Avengers arc was basically the end
of their marriage.
You can blame the Phoenix for that divorce.
Number 4 - Superman and Wonder Woman
This was such a big deal when they got together
in the New 52 comics.
They’d already done the story in Kingdom
Come, but that was an alternate universe and
not considered canon of the mai versions of
the characters.
New 52 was the DC reboot that established
a single continuity and Superman Wonder Woman
was one of the first big WTFs.
You can let me know whether you love them
together or totally hate the idea.
It’s like when Marvel rebooted Spider-Man
so that he wasn’t married to Mary Jane anymore.
It’s hard to believe they didn’t let these
two A-Listers date before.
Part of the attraction is that they’re both
alien gods so far on the fringe that they’re
pretty much undateable outside of a certain
tier.
Like unless you are nearly indestructible,
you are not going to be able to have a sexual
relationship with one of them or carry their
child.
I remember when I read Kingdom Come for the
first time and saw Wonder Woman pregnant.
All I could think about was what that baby’s
powers would be.
Their powers both appear similar but there’s
a lot of celestial magic tied to wonder woman’s
origin so theories below.
What would their kid be like?
Number 3 - Green Arrow and Black Canary
I know Arrow teased it a little, but since
they’re telling an origin story, there’s
no way Oliver is going to get married in the
second season.
In the comics it was a lot of fun.
There interesting thing about them breaking
up in the comics was that it happened after
Oliver killed Prometheus after Prometheus
killed Roy Harper’s daughter.
That was just a string of tragedies.
I’d be surprised if any marriage could survive
that.
That was also just a terrible story for Roy,
somebody make sure Colton Haynes stays away
from that.
Reading it will just make him depressed.
Number 2 - Batman and Catwoman
If you ever read the Earth 2 comics, the Huntress
was the daughter of Batman and the Selina
Kyle Catwoman.
Her name was Helena Wayne.
That was an alternate universe version.
The version that Arrow did was Helena Bertinelli.
They never got married in the main comics,
but they had sex so many times you’d think
they were living together.
Rule #1 of Batman relationships is that nothing
lasts forever, even with a Lazarus Pit.
They did get together in the new 52 comics,
but their relationship is described as being
estranged.
Which basically means you broke up but you
still booty call each other with the bat signal
on occasion.
I’m interested to see what kind of a relationship
the Gotham tv show is going to give the bruce
wayne and catwoman characters since they’re
only little kids.
I’m guessing they’ll just become good
friends that help each other out.
Just for reference, I think Bruce Wayne is
supposed to be about 13 on the show.
and my Number 1 Comic Book couple - Gambit
and Rogue
The thing that really made me love the two
of them together was the 90s cartoon.
I watched that more than I read the comics.
The fun thing about the two of them was that
they were always a pair of loveable scoundrels.
They weren’t royalty like Storm and Black
Panther, so the seemed more like people you
would want to hang out with.
That’s the problem with a lot of the A-List
mega superheroes.
It’s almost like the more powerful you get
the more uptight you get.
Gambit and Rogue were the couple that made
you forget about Apocalypse and Magneto.
Lately the comics haven’t been so nice to
them.
Gambit became one of Apocalypse’s four horsemen
but in his spinoff comic they have teased
a reconcilliation.
Rule Number 1 of any comic book couple: Nothing
lasts forever.
But rule number 2 is everything comes back
around eventually.
So even if people break up, they’ll probably
get back together at some point.
There’s always something bad about getting
everything you want.
In the life of a comic book superhero, nothing
is permanent.
So the minute you have everything, something
jumps out to stab you in the back.
A villain returns, like Malcolm Merlyn.
Just to tie it back to Arrow.
You get distracted and new threats develop,
like Count Vertigo and your girlfriends face
shines so brightly that you can’t see the
shadows moving in the distance.
Shadows in this case being the League of Assassins
and Ra’s Al Ghul.
As a fan of the characters, that’s the big
reason I don’t want the show to completely
go there.
Oliver and Felicity will always be a family
with the rest of Team Arrow, but only in the
sense you deeply care about each other.
Let me know if you agree, but I feel like
it’s an unspoken rule that the biggest superheroes
and supervillains don’t get to have traditional
happy families.
They can have children, but they can’t have
normal relationships.
Batman has Talia and Damien, but that doesn’t
end well at all.
Oliver in the comics has Connor and they have
a terrible relationship.
Here’s a big question for you guys.
If Oliver and Felicity ever really did get
together, do you think it would kill the dynamic
in the group.
The minute he started having sex with black
canary everything went south.
There’s no wrong answer, but I feel like
not knowing how they’ll end up is more exciting
than seeing it at the risk of being disappointed
after.
On to Katana, the big news is that Devin Aoki
has been replaced by Rila Fukushima because
of scheduling conflicts.
When they say scheduling conflicts, usually
what happens is actors get signed to a contract
for a specific period of time when the show
expects to be filming their scenes.
Shooting days get moved around all the time,
so it’s likely that Devin Aoki’s shooting
schedule for Arrow changed and overlapped
with some other movie she was doing or vis
versa.
Arrow was probably getting ready to film some
Katana scenes and needed an actress, so they
find a new Katana.
It just so happens that their new actress
was also Yukio in the last Wolverine movie.
One step closer to a Marvel DC crossover.
I did a big video explaining Katana’s backstory
in the comics that I’ll link in the description.
But the idea is that the show will use her
in the Hong Kong flashbacks and in the present.
Usually when characters from the flashbacks
come forward it’s because they’re tied
up in the big villain arc.
Like Black Canary and Slade in season 2.
This season Ra’s Al Ghul is the big bad,
so if Katana is going to show up in the past
and the present.
It probably has something to do with him and
the League of Assassins.
That makes me wonder if The League of Assassins
has something to do with Amanda Waller’s
Hong Kong operation.
They do a good job of putting clues about
the big villain arc in the season premiere
every year so make sure to keep your eyes
peeled for things that connect Katana, Oliver,
Amanda Waller and Ra’s Al Ghul.
Fukushima is a great action actress so she
will be a total badass on Arrow.
Speaking of crossover characters, there’s
another Tommy Flashback scene in Hong Kong.
Supposedly Tommy is there for some unrelated
reason and Oliver almost runs into him.
Which makes me wonder if Malcolm Merlyn will
show in the flashbacks too.
He was back in starling city while oliver
was away for that 5 year period.
Merlyn’s time with the league of assassins
preceded Oliver’s shipwreck.
So far he hasn’t been in any of the promos
yet.
They should be releasing the now infamous
Olicity Kiss one, so maybe they’ll expand
that and add some Merlyn.
I’m not expecting to see any of the other
guest comic book characters in promos, other
than Ray Palmer.
They’ll probably release some more footage
of him to explain his character a little better.